All right, Jorge Myszne,
thank you so much for joining us
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thank you.
Thank you for having me.
So great to have you.
We know each other from
the J-Ventures Fund.
And I just love how I get to meet
all these incredible people
through this capitalistic Kibbutz.
Jorge, you have a fascinating story
which I can't wait to hear on this show
about your journey from Uruguay
to Israel to the US.
The startup that you sold to Qualcomm.
Your amazing work
at Intel and on WiFi
and things that I have no idea about.
And finally about your new startup
which, as you mentioned,
you grinding on which I love.
Jorge, who are you?
Give me the rundown.
Okay. So, originally I was born in Uruguay
in South America.
And then got married
and moved to Israel when I was 26.
And started to work at Intel,
at the WiFi team at Intel.
When I got there, we were kind of
a small startup inside Intel.
So, I think we were about 30 people.
And then fast forward 2007
I left Intel to start my first startup
and we were about 1500
I think at Intel at that time
on the WiFi team.
And after the Centrino and after
the whole revolution of WiFi
and went with other three partners
and we started Wilocity,
It was 60 gigahertz WiFi chipset company.
And together with that company,
in 2010, so I moved to the Bay Area
to start the operations here
in the Bay Area.
And then 2014, Qualcomm acquired us. Moved to Qualcomm
Wait wait wait. Jorge, the transition
from Uruguay to Israel,
not that common.
Going straight into Intel,
what was that about?
So, you get married and you decide
to just move your whole life to Israel.
Yeah, actually.
So, I started in Uruguay.
I did my undergrad and second degree
a master's degree there.
And I always wanted to go to Israel
and move to Israel.
So, I had the opportunity when I was 18
to go because Uruguay's in the south.
So, the scholar year is the opposite.
Right.
So, when I was about to start in Israel,
so, I already did half a year
in college in Uruguay.
So you know it's just a bunch of excuses.
Why not?
But then I said,
"Okay, well I already started,
so let's make it here, etc."
So, bottom line, I just finished there.
And that was the next stage
and the next phase when I could say,
"Okay, that's the time."
So, with my current wife,
so, we said, "Okay, let's go."
So, actually we got married
and a month later we were in Israel
sleeping on,
eating on the floor.
Wonderful.
And you joined Intel,
you joined the WiFi team
during the WiFi revolution.
What was that like working on technologies
that really shape how we interface
with the world today,
especially my generation?
Yeah, it was great.
And I think it was a great journey.
And coming from a big company
and seeing how that evolved.
It was great.
So, it started with
kind of one megabit per second
and it was kind of a big revolution
just to get one megabit per second.
And then it becomes that great thing
with all the operation at some point.
I was in charge of one
of the generations
and we were manufacturing
50 million chipsets a year.
And it was really great and
especially when Intel decided to go
all in with the Centrino
and made the WiFi part
of the branding of the Centrino
and getting, at that time was McDonald's,
getting hot spots in McDonald's
because, of course, you need both sides.
That was great.
And just going everywhere and
just the pride of going somewhere
and say
"Ah, that is the chip that I designed."
That was pretty fun.
Amazing. Amazing. Okay.
And then from there,
you go with a few partners
and you move on to Wilocity.
And there you developed technology
that you actually sell to Qualcomm.
Right?
Yeah.
So what was that like?
Moving from a huge corporation
like Intel and going to create
a startup which is you said,
60 gigahertz?
Yeah.
So, the way WiFi works
it's bands there are free,
ISM bands.
So, 2.4 and 5 gigahertz
are bands that everybody can use.
And at some point the FCCs of the world
just took 60, a band around 60 gigahertz,
and said, "Okay, this band is now ISM."
And the reason for that is because
of the size of the molecules of oxygen.
So, there is more absorption than
even in higher frequencies.
So, basically, nobody wants to use it.
It's not a good frequency to use
because of there is a lot of loss.
So, that's why they said,
"Okay, you know what?
Whoever wants to use it, can use it."
And that's when we said,
"Okay. We need to use it for indoor
so not very long range."
But because of the real estate
that you have there,
the bandwidth that you have there.
So, you can go very, very,
wide.
That means very, very fast.
So, our first product was
4.6 gigabits per second.
Wow.
And today, the ...
goes all the way to
100 gigabits per second. Wireless.
Incredible.
And then what were you doing at Qualcomm?
So, when we were acquired by Qualcomm,
so basically, a couple of years earlier,
Qualcomm acquired another
company called Atheros.
That was the big WiFi and became
a big communications company,
not just WiFi at some point.
So, when they acquired Atheros,
actually, they became kind of
the communications group inside Qualcomm.
So when we were acquired,
we merged into the Atheros group
and basically took over the products
of Wilocity inside Qualcomm
and just merging to the communications team
and build the whole combo of WiFi and WiGig,
that is the name of
60 gigahertz technology, etc.
Wow. That's very very interesting.
And now fast forward to today.
You're acting both as an angel investor
as part of J-Ventures,
but you're also
running your own company.
I'd love to hear about this tension
between these two things.
So on one hand,
we meet on a monthly basis,
before physically now virtually,
to look at different startups
and different opportunities.
Yet you yourself
are acting the same role
as the entrepreneurs we're evaluating.
So, how does that play out?
It's actually kind of funny
because sometimes you are
on one side of the table
and others you are
on the other side of the table.
So you learn to, actually you learn a lot
from being on both sides
of the table.
Of course.
So you know as an entrepreneur,
when you act as the VC.
So, you understand
what they are looking for.
So, you know how to sell
your pitch better on one side.
On the flip side you understand also the guy
that is coming and pitching to you
probably for the first,
usually at J-Ventures for the first time
or the first initial phases,
so you try to actually,
you try to help them.
So I find myself a lot of times
just whether we decide to invest
as a fund or myself personally,
just helping them.
And it happened in several cases.
For example, one of the companies
that we have that could have
a relationship in South America.
So, I connected them
with some companies that I know
and tried to get them going. Right.
So, you appreciate much more both sides.
Right. And well, you use the intel
that you get on both sides
when you are on the other side.
100%.
I'm getting so much
insight and inspiration myself
coming in as a student and an engineer
and I'm going to be an entrepreneur
hopefully soon.
And hopefully pitching to funds
and angel groups like J-Ventures.
And I think that just understanding
the questions that are being asked.
It's so phenomenal.
And it's really humbling to see
how many different things you can think of
and what are the common pitfalls
and how much you can learn
from every single person,
like I'm learning from you
through J-Ventures.
So it's really, really great.
Kameleon, talk to me a little bit about that.
Kameleon is the latest one.
So after I took some time off -
The latest adventure.
Yeah.
So, I took some time off
After a long time that I was grinding.
I took some time off.
Spent some time with the family.
We had a great road trip
across the US from coast to coast.
So, at some point I said,
"Okay, now it's time to go back
to the trenches."
So actually I partnered
with two other guys.
One of them is also a guy
that I worked with at Wilocity.
And we started Kameleon
We are trying to solve
the cyber-security problem
but from the foundation.
So there is a lot of companies
working on the cyberspace.
But we see that basically
at the end of the day,
all the software
runs on top of hardware.
And that hardware
was never designed for security.
So it's a patch
on top of a patch
on top of a patch.
And what we see is that
unless you build a strong base,
doesn't matter what you build on top,
at the end of the day
you can always come underneath.
Right.
So, this is what we are doing.
And basically, Kamaleon is building
what we call the SPU.
It's a security processing unit
that is a companion device to any system
but in particular, right now,
we are working on PCs and servers
and protect the system from time zero.
So, all the boot of the system
and then during runtime,
and isolates completely
the attackers from the defenders
and gives a very secure environment
for the defenders
where they can trust.
And trust here is a big, big word.
They can trust what they see.
They cannot be fooled.
And they get full visibility
on the system,
how it's working and what's going on.
Is that why it's called Kameleon
because it can change its color
based on what you want it to,
so that it blends with the environment?
Yeah.
So, one of the applications
that we are also doing is what it's called
Moving Target Defense.
And basically, what you do
is you change the memory map
of the of the software
that it's running in runtime.
So, that's where the Kameleon is coming.
We move things around
so when attacker wants to
attack the system,
they don't know where,
basically where the entrance is
So, you are moving the windows
and the doors all the time. Right.
So, when they try to get into the house,
they don't know where to enter from.
Right. That makes a lot of sense.
And I have to ask,
going from corporate to startup
to corporate to now investor,
what are some things
that you're bringing with you
into this newest venture
because you must be approaching this
with a little bit more insight,
if not a lot more insight
than you had before.
So what are some of the key things
that you and your partner set out
and you knew off the bat
that perhaps Jorge of Wilocity
in its early days didn't know?
I think that working on both sides,
on small companies and on big companies,
you understand the motivations
behind what people do.
At the end of the day,
you deal with people.
You do business with people.
Right.
Doesn't matter if it's Intel,
Qualcomm, Wilocity.
Small, big, medium. It's all the same.
At the end of the day,
you need to try and understand
what is driving that person.
What is the level of risk
that he's willing to take and why?
So having worked in big companies,
small companies, usually Americans,
but doesn't necessarily need to be.
You get to, at least, understand or recognize
what are the things that drive people.
What is the all the,
especially in the corporate,
so, the internal politics at the corporate.
And who are the right people to talk to.
What is that you need to offer.
Find the person that can help you -
You know I think it's so cool
that you're dealing with
the very low level of technology,
very hard core technology,
yet when I ask you about the things
that you're taking with you
from your previous experiences,
you're not saying
I'm taking more knowledge and
more expertise in that domain.
But you're saying I'm taking
the understanding that at the end
it's all about people
and it's all about relationships, right?
Yeah. And at the end of the day if you want,
even though it's still silicon
and semiconductor,
I was doing communications.
Now it's security. It's systems.
So it's the expertise you know
You can always find good people
and build a good team,
but at the end of the day,
you need to know how to build
the whole system,
especially when you are
trying to change some conventions, right.
When I talk about cyber-security,
nobody thinks about hardware.
Everybody thinks about software,
antivirus or whatever.
Right.
So, just shifting, making that part of the timeshift
it's not trivial.
And at the end of the day,
you need to find the right people
that are willing to take that leap of faith
with you.
And the risk, of course.
Right, and say
"Okay, we need to fix this
from the foundation.
We need to build the right foundation."
And it's not another feature,
and if it's white or black or whatever.
Right. Are there more,
I'm trying to think of things
that I would wanna take for myself
as I approach my own ventures later on
and my own experiences
in the tech industry.
What are some of the earned secrets
that you've accumulated over the years
in terms of the products that you're building
and communicating with customers
and with different people?
I think at the end of the day,
you need to be very careful
not to get in love with the technology,
but have a technology
that solves a real problem.
Okay.
The technology is the consequence
and not the compass, right.
So you need to be very, very careful.
As a technical people
we always fall in love
with the technology.
But at the end of the day
when you go to a potential customer,
you need to understand their pain
and see how the technology
solves their pain and not just,
"Well, this is cool.
This technology is really cool."
So, I think that this is
probably the main thing in terms of
what you do with your things when
and being upfront.
I think it's the other one.
As a startup, you are always
with less resources than you want
and you are always
probably promising a little bit
more than what you really have.
And it's kind of a
...
So while I think it's okay, I mean,
everybody understands that.
You need to be very, very upfront.
You don't want to put your
potential customers and your champions
inside a company in a bad position.
So you need to be very, very open
and develop that relationship with them
so they know what they have
and they can help you manage that
and navigate the company.
They know that better than you.
I love it. I love it.
Jorge, we almost have to end,
but I have to ask you my favorite question.
Three words that you would use
to describe yourself
or that your co-founders
from either startup would use
to describe you as.
Three words.
Adventurous.
Okay.
I've been going up and down,
right and left and things that I didn't
know exactly how they will end.
Grit.
Okay.
Sometimes, people always ask me
why I left a big corporate
with a big salary
and go back to the trenches.
But that's what I like.
And the third one I think it's
citizen of the world.
Having lived in three countries now,
at least 10 years on each,
you get a little bit of each one with you.
And you are always missing
a little bit of each one.
I love it. I love it.
Wonderful.
Jorge, thank you so much
for the inspiration and
for the time.
I really appreciate it.
And best of luck with Kameleon.
Great. Happy to be here.
Thank you.
Toda raba. Bye Bye.